well let's talk about black love for a
second because you and plato had turned
into relationship
goals he shared the dm that you know
sparked everything between you two
recently and it went
viral so that being said what do you
think it is that people
admire so much about your relationship i
think
what they admire the most is that they
were wrong
in the beginning like there was a lot of
false narratives that kind of surrounded
our love
i think one of the biggest ones was is
it a pr stunt
and i think because we're not so
transparent and we don't share
everything
with anything it's easy for people to
put you know a narrative or a story
behind something
and then other people run with it
because they don't understand and when
you don't understand you try to make
yourself understand
right and that's when all these rumors
start circulating so
i think they love it because i think
they had an aha moment where there's
like damn it was wrong this is really
genuine
and with anything when you falsely judge
something and then you figure out it's
better than what you expected i feel
like it creates some sort of
like connection to it so i think you
know we share what we share but
it's very low-key that's so real
and that makes me think of another
relationship i feel like they falsely
judge
and it's between you and cardi b you two
are essentially like in the same
family when it comes to relationships
can you talk a little bit about what's
the camaraderie like between you two
i think people just put stories on what
they don't understand
and for me i'm a very low-key person and
i feel like when you
kind of put your attention and when you
address the negative things that come
with it that's when people kind of
create stories
i feel like it's so easy for people to
try to put you two up against each other
because they don't see your relationship
that often
and i basically i just wanted you to say
what's real
and let it go but if that's your answer
we can just keep it at that
yeah i think i think throughout the
years they've tried to put me against so
many
other other female rappers i feel like
it's a female rapping because they don't
do it
with any of the r b girls not that i've
seen the rap environment
is just it's it's it has a it's
historically
aggressive it's historically you know
um not a good environment
when females are winning and they try to
put females against each other and
honestly
sometimes it's the fan bases yeah it's
like
like sometimes that fan bases kind of
influence the person that they're
supporting
um so i try not to feed into any of that
and honestly i just mind my business
girl
girl sometimes that's all you gotta do i
get it i totally get it
well people also love how you carry
yourself you know your brand your
confidence
and i think it's easy to think that you
are like that 24
7 but do you have your off days and if
so how do you snap yourself back
mentally i think my off days are
days when i'm just really hard on myself
yeah
um sometimes i'm just like damn i'm not
where i want to be right now
sometimes i'm hella bloated and i'm like
i feel disgusting and
it don't help cause i'm eating
everything in my cabinet um
sometimes i'm just like i'm just i think
my toxic trait is i'm really hard on
myself
like i'm not no one could ever make me
feel a way about me but me
um so it's like i think that's when i
have to really
like i talked about reflection that's
when i really have to sit in the mirror
and i'm just like okay why are you
feeling how you feeling and how can you
fix it
because it's easy to just go minutes
even hours
on just like this negative ass
conversation in your head
yeah i'm just like why do i keep talking
about myself
i'm hurting my own feelings yeah i'm
like hurting i'm hurting my own
feelings and i'm just like okay this
isn't good and you're like
tearing yourself down so why don't we
reverse this
why don't you start saying your positive
affirmations
and why don't you get yourself out of
this little negative bubble because
everything is everything is i've learned
is an option so i have to opt out of
being negative because being negative is
really easy believe it or not
so um yeah on those days i have to i
have to reflect and
i have to make that choice if i can if i
can't make that choice and i'll just go
to sleep
right go to sleep try again tomorrow
sometimes that's all you need
really let's talk about icy university
for a second professor icee since we're
talking about all these
gems you have to offer people instead of
me doing a question
a q a on twitter or instagram
i wanted to create a platform that
you know is accessible at any time or
day
something that will live forever instead
of my fans having to screenshot
something or i don't know whatever they
do to hold on to a piece of valuable
information so
i invested in myself meaning i also
invested into my fans with this
knowledge because knowledge is power and
i like to empower my fans
so that's the reason why i created ic
universities because they always ask me
the same questions over and over again
um how do you
[Music]
start a business right how how do you
have your confidence how to do this how
to do that so instead of me just going
on a rant
i created you know something cute for
the girls and for the boys
to always go back to all right so is
this a program you want to offer at a
standing university maybe usc in the
future
i'm definitely going to be offering this
um
at usc once i drop
pretty british music i'm not sure if
it'll be for a year or or if it'll be
for a semester but
i'll definitely be teaching an elective
at a university
i love that that's so cool that's so
cool fans were surprised to learn that
your mom was
the baddie in the nelly in dmx video
has she ever told you any stories about
those days for her
yeah she really did um and it's crazy
because
it's crazy how everything just kind of
gets oversaturated and walked
and you know watered down but my mom was
telling me that video vixens
actually were really respected back in
the days
they had booking agents they had super
high fees
um and they were considered like just
just models like any other model that
was out there they were equivalent to
that and they would get booked on that
rate
and then it's crazy because i ain't
gonna say no names because it's not for
me to do that but she name drops
which is not name drums but she shares
the girls who kind of effed it up for
everybody
who are willing to work at a lower rate
who are willing to
you know do crazy things for their roles
and that's how you know the value of the
video vixen went down but it used to
actually have a really good
um connotation you want to know that's
crazy because i didn't want to
call her a video vixen on purpose like
no right no but i
was crazy and she got offended one day
because i was talking about
the shift of it and the way that i was
talking about it because i'm
um in this generation now where video
vixens
that term isn't really respected she was
like wait hold on like no let me remind
you
and she kind of educated me on like like
that used to be a good thing
and if you were that you were like that
girl but you know some girls came in
and kind of you know you know just made
the value go down
yeah yeah okay before i let you go i
have two more questions
um one these birken brats girl
it's adorable first of all i want to
know do you voice each bag
is that you um i have some help on the
first one but other than that
yes it's it's me honestly it's hella
funny because
it's like like when i was a little girl
i was the only child for about 11 years
so i'm hella creative because i spent a
lot of time with myself
so i'm spending a lot of time with
myself in quarantine so i just had to
like i was visualizing i was gonna be
hella funny to give my birkens
some personality yes it's so and i love
how you don't just think about it you
actually
you know initiate the creative idea
because it's hilarious it's really cute
and then the friday skit was funny as
well you have to get into acting
eventually or try that thank you yeah
okay before i let you go we have to talk
about voting you're part of iheart
media's
why i'm voting campaign you're quiet on
social media when it comes to politics
for the most part but why did you feel
like
this was something you had to be a part
of to let your fans know
you have to vote um
i think the actions that you take behind
the scenes are
more important i wouldn't say more
important
but to me i feel like that's when
the work that that counts really matters
because
um it's one thing to be local but
they're not really doing things behind
the scenes
so yes i may be quiet
compared to others when it comes to
political standpoints but
i do a lot of things behind the thing
behind the scenes to make sure that
the change is happening um but the
reason why
i'm very vocal i at this
time in my career is because i realized
that
um my platform is not only used
should not only be used for music for
fashion
for glamour for you know escapism
um because that's what entertainment is
especially in this era but
i think it's important to educate i
think it's important to spread awareness
especially because i have this
platform where people look up to me when
people
see people who look like them when
people see people who they can
you know connect with doing something
for a positive change
i think that's that's so satisfying to
me so
i'm doing that to encourage my followers
to
to you know take a stand because when i
was young when i was in high school
i didn't see nobody who looked like me
or somebody who i look up to
you know voting or doing other things
that are positive for the community so i
i didn't care
so when i reflect and i think back to
those moments i'm like you know what i
should be voicing what i am doing on and
off the screen
just so that they know that they are
important that their voice matters
and that if they did take action it will
make a difference